so let me ask you you've been doing
these remote conversations with experts
and people that are facing challenges
because of this horrible pandemic and
you've got this new episode Oprah toxic
Ovid 19 on Apple TV plus it's being seen
by people in a hundred different
countries but you specifically wanted to
focus on how coca 19 is affecting black
Americans and you've spoken to a number
of people who've given you a perspective
that I don't think a lot of people when
this pandemic first broke we're thinking
about because definitely the most
marginalized people in our society are
not thought of at times of crises like
this what did you what did you learn
through these discussions what I learned
is is that there's a difference between
communicating and connecting and so I
think that the message that was
communicated that if you have a
pre-existing condition was a valid
message but it did not connect to the
audience in a way that they could hear
pre-existing means you if you are taking
medication for hypertension means you if
you are on an inhaler for asthma means
you your son your nephews your cousins
means you if you are a diabetic or even
pre-diabetic if you have any lung issues
it means you so I think that just like
so many people when this was happening
in new Han we thought that was over
there we I think all of us were guilty
to an extent perhaps maybe not you cuz
you're in the news and you could see how
it was moving but I think a lot of
Americans thought oh that was that was
them over there and then I talked to
African Americans in Milwaukee my former
hometown where I grew up on welfare many
years with my mother living there on
North ninth Street and you know the
folks in Milwaukee were saying to me we
heard about it in Washington but
Washington was way over there and we
didn't think that they had anything to
do with us because that's way over there
we didn't think it would be and directly
in our community and so when
the head of the family
Lawrence ended up with a cold they
thought it was just a cold and then when
it got progressively worse in three days
and on the fourth day you're going to
the hospital they didn't expect for him
to be dead by the fifth so I just have
to say it's taking people out it's real
and this is what I want to say to our
community in particular because I think
people now are hearing the message
because media is now putting this on
high alert for for all people and black
people to understand that it affects us
if their pre-existing conditions but I
think people aren't still getting the
message that it's not just the people
who you see have it or you think might
have it it's the people who are
asymptomatic it's why in my own house
one of my beloved daughters from South
Africa wanted to come home from Stanford
and I said he can't come because there's
no way for me to get you here you can't
take a train not gonna be on a bus not
gonna be on a plane opening yourself up
to everybody their only way you can come
is that can send security to get you and
then you put security in danger cuz I
don't know where you've been or who
you've been around and so that daughter
is still living alone in her own
apartment and we all FaceTime every
night but I didn't let her come into the
to the space be just because I thought
even if you endanger one other person
who has to come and get you so it's not
not the people who you know have it who
were sneezing and aches and pains it's
the people who perhaps are asymptomatic
and at the beginning of the series I had
the pleasure of interviewing a jurist
and his wife who were in quarantine in
in New Mexico never did they show a
symptom ever
they were asymptomatic and never through
the hole to two weeks quarantine and
then after did they ever show a symptom
so I think it's all of these people who
perhaps could be carriers and then
bringing it into your home so it's not
just I want to say to folks not just
isolating your stuff but don't let
anybody else come in your house right
and you you're it so a couple of points
that you just made that I want to sort
of focus on you talked about Milwaukee
and what we've seen a really distressing
statistic that we've seen replicated
over and over again is in cities and in
states where black people are not the
majority they are disproportionately
affected by coab in nineteen seventy
percent of the deaths in chicago our
black americans yet they only make up
30% of the population and you spoke to
their glory light but what did she tell
you well she told me that you know the
same thing i think that she shared at
that news conference only she spoken in
depth about the numbers just take your
breath away and how difficult it is when
you are living in housing where you have
no way of getting away from the rest of
the people in the house except to close
off a room and put yourself in a room
how social distancing in the
african-american community is far more
difficult in the african-american and
brown community because you have more
people living in the home and I talked
to a minister on the south side of
Chicago for this series who lost his
sister and his best friend since high
school within the same couple of days
Dudek ovid wasn't able to be with either
of them at the end and wasn't even able
to have a funeral I think that's what
people don't understand is that it's
taking people out the family in
Milwaukee told me they couldn't believe
that in five days their family member
was gone they're still looking at the
chair that he held everything sat in and
every night in the living room you just
can't believe they're sharing with me
that we hear 14 days they thought they
had 14 days because you don't have 14
days if the virus hits it hits your
lungs you're out you're gone and so for
those who can't recover particularly
with pre-existing conditions and all the
people I talked to also had pre-existing
conditions diabetes heart disease
hypertension and so III
I'm using every platform that I know of
that's why Apple TV is allowing own to
broadcast because it's not even a matter
of you know business it's just a matter
of how many people can you reach to get
this message across so I thank you for
the opportunity also of course it's me
that honored to be able to talk to you
about such an important subject can you
also you also spoke to Nicole Hannah
Jones who I'm a huge fan of who's such a
wonderful am i as a my New York Times
and you know Nicole's been writing and
talking about this a lot and you know
she highlights things I think that
sometimes people do not stop and think
about when we talk about como
comorbidities or the fact that a lot of
black and brown people will be your
postal worker your cashier your grocer
they live in areas where they are
perhaps more prone to asthma because
they're closer to highways in some parts
of the country or live in areas where
there have been you know there's been
toxic dumps or toxic waste or are living
in environments that don't allow you to
have the best access to health care to
have the best access to insurance and so
all of the other structural issues that
have been in place to cause people to be
oppressed for for centuries are in play
when it comes to this disease so if you
were in a position where you literally
were just trying to make ends meet to
take care of yourself and to you know
get get health insurance and to be able
to benefit your health and then
something like this strikes it's it's
almost impossible to over overcome it
and you know that's one of the things
I've been thinking about for when we
actually get through this which we we we
all know that this will eventually pass
and we will get through it and I think
for every one of us glad we come away
from this experience changed and if it
doesn't change you in some way then you
missed the point I don't want to see
what has to happen to actually change
you and I think when we come out on the
other side every person
not just in America but throughout the
world is going to be more appreciative
of the simple things in life the things
that you can't do now that you took for
granted taking a walk going for a bike
ride going to the store buying what you
want even sharing a hug
being able to congregate with your
friends all those feelings that we're
having now everything that you're
missing everything that you're feeling
anxiety about that's what this moment is
supposed to slow us down and get us to
consider I believe deeply spiritually in
my soul that along with all the
scientific biological stuff that's
happening that there is a major
spiritual calling here and and and and
and a truth awakening for for the world
for the humans of the world to come out
on the other side better than we were
when we went in and so what is going to
be called for is for each of us those of
us who have to to put ourselves in a
position to be more open to happen to
help the have-nots because they're going
to be a lot more have-nots in every area
of life
so it's caused me to think more
seriously about what I really want to do
with the rest of my life you know if I
am blessed to be spared from this this
disease and how I want to use my
philanthropy in a way to lift other
people up so yes III donating ten
million dollars but that's just a start
you know because whatever is happening
now with people needing food banks and
people needing services is gonna be ten
times worse on the other side of this